♪ ♪
>> Sean: THE PSYCHOTIC
HATE-TRUMP MEDIA MOB, THEY ARE
SCRAMBLING AFTER A SHAKE-UP AT
NBC NEWS, SOON-TO-BE FORMER
GERMAN ANTI-LOCKE IS OUT.
TRACE GALLAGHER STANDING LIVE IN
OUR WEST COAST NEWSROOM WITH OUR
REPORT.
WOW, ATTORNEY GENERAL, CHRIS
MATTHEWS, PAT LAUER, ANDY LUCK.
A LOT OF BIG NAMES THEY ARE.
>> WITHOUT THE DEPARTURE WAS A
BIG STORY HERE UNTIL
TUCKER CARLSON WAS TOLD THE
NEW YORK ATTORNEY GENERAL IS
INVESTIGATING A LITANY OF
SEXUAL ASSAULT CLAIMS.
YOU WILL RECALL IT WAS AND A
LACK WHO REFUSED TO AIR RONAN
FARROW’S EXPOSE ON THE
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATIONS
AGAINST HARVEY WEINSTEIN, SAYING
IT WASN’T FIT FOR AIR.
SO RONAN PHARAOH TOOK IT TO THE
NEW YORKER IN WON A PULITZER.
IT WAS ALSO ANDY LACK THAT
DECIDED THE SEXUAL ASSAULT
ALLEGATIONS BY MATT LAUER SHOULD
BE INVESTIGATED BY FELLOW NBC
EXECUTIVES INSTEAD OF OUTSIDE
INVESTIGATORS.
NBC NEWS TOLD US IT’S NOT AWARE
OF ANY INQUIRY BY THE NEW YORK
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WHICH IS ODD,
CONSIDERING FORMER NBC
CORRESPONDENT AND FOX NEWS
ANCHOR LINDA VESTER SAID THE
NEW YORK AG’S OFFICE INTERVIEWED
HER ABOUT THE INVESTIGATION
THREE MONTHS AGO.
>> Sean: YEAH, I TEND TO